make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay too powerful for Marvel movies
Apocalypse Now in order to understand
the nature of Apocalypse we have to kind
of understand how mutants work in Marvel
Comics so for those of you guys who are
new to Marvel if you all you've ever
seen his movies and all you really know
is just the concept of mutant right so
there's just like mutants and nominees
and that's it the reality is that
mutants aren't super league aren't
aren't like overly convoluted but there
are different quote-unquote levels of
utens right so there isn't really a
power hierarchy here but we're just
gonna kind of start with proto muse
right so like they're not the most
powerful ones they're just a group of
mutants so and the idea here is that in
the early days of humanity you have the
Celestials who showed up on Earth by
celestial beings and they created the
deviants and they created the Eternals
and then they modified the genes at
baseline humans and they said somewhere
along the line those genes are gonna
activate when we don't know but like
we'll be back when they do and just make
sure you guys are okay anyway what is up
happening here is somewhere along the
line between the time that Selene popped
up and the time that apocalypse arrived
and there were proto mutants and what
this means is that these mutant genes
activated in like a small subset of
humanity and then by whatever man or
whatever means they were wiped away now
the only proto mutant that's left is a
guy named Gabriel Shepard and he can do
all kinds of cool stuff but aside from
him there are no more pure or proto
mutants they don't exist following them
then you have the birth of Saleem now
Selene is what we call an external the
idea behind Selene and the externals is
that Selene is essentially like a life
force vampire right so like she has to
absorb the life force of other people or
to keep herself alive but she's been
around for like ten thousand years so
she's been doing a pretty good job of it
so far now with regards to externals
these are mutants who are legitimately
immortal with the exception of being
killed through physical contact it
basically means that shy of having their
heads cut off the way the Gideon got his
head cut off by cable though live until
like the universe ends immortality's
kind of a finicky thing anyway so the
idea behind this was that when
apocalypse first showed up Marvel teased
the notion that he may have been an
external they've never actually
confirmed it but they teased it and the
reason why was because when the time
came that his powers manifested which
really to go into in this isn't overly
convoluted and ridiculous when his
powers manifested he had size alteration
enhanced durability and he was believed
that he was immortal with everything
with apocalypse basically changed when
it came to the introduction of cable and
here's what I mean by that those are
guys who saw Deadpool - you know who
cable his right leg he's Josh Brolin
basically what ended up happening is in
in the the far distant future like forth
years in the future apocalypse
successfully managed to conquer the
world and that's the left the world that
cable was raised it now there's also
strife things like that we'll talk about
that in future video but in a future
cable was under the under the heel
basically in a world that was ruled by
apocalypse and because it was so harsh
and cruel cable basically made it his
mission to travel back in time and to
stop apocalypse before he could rise to
power and so what ends up happening is
that when apocalypse leas Egypt and
taking his social Darwinist perspective
which means only the strong deserve to
survive and took it out into the world
and sort of making himself like a
warlord and started like forcing
civilizations to fight each other and
instigating civil wars and creating his
riders of the dark which was like this
giant army that he would use to like
test people to see whether or not they
could withstand an army and so on anyway
when he did that he went out into the
world Apocalypse really discovered like
celestial technology and celestial
technology was again technology left
behind when Celestials visited earth for
the second time I think when they ended
up visiting to either wipe out the
deviants or when they showed up to like
Odin and Zeus and all those guys and
they were like stop interfering in the
affairs of mortal men like stay
hands-off but the idea behind this was
that cable traveling into the past
basically encountered apocalypse and
when he fought him both of them injured
each other but cable left apocalypse for
dead he loses his arm in the process and
the techno-organic virus inside cable
infiltrated and went into apocalypse and
when it did it gave up our clothes the
ability to understand celestial
technology and so when that happened
apocalypse and turn started bonding
celestial technology to himself and what
that did is it gave up pocalypse
a whole host of powers and made him
virtually indestructible now apocalypse
cannot warp reality and apocalypse has a
huge caveat that we'll get to here in a
second but he cannot warp reality
however what he can do is he has
telepathy he has telekinesis he can grow
and shrink to any size
he can give himself any superhuman power
whatsoever so super strength energy
projection all kinds of different stuff
he can increase his own durability which
means he can make himself denser I mean
he can do all kinds of stuff like he
said he's a science genius see it's it's
crazy the kind of power he possesses
apocalypse is so powerful the x-men have
never actually been able to defeat him
because of this what ended up happening
here is apocalypse went forward and
triggers again took a social Darwinist
perspective with him but started like
manipulating everything around him that
he saw and alike like fighting off
against people and then creating
horsemen and these horsemen would
basically be individuals who would have
powers imbued to them if they didn't
have powers or if they did have powers
they would be restructured and reworked
and order to make them conducive
to the goal of apocalypse so say that
apocalypse shows up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right like sits down
to the MCU and says okay I am here now
and now I want to face off against the
Avengers
I want to conquer the world or the very
least you would say I want to test the
world and see whether or not the world
is worth you know whether or not it's
worth being allowed to live or anything
like that I want to see who the worthy
are and so what do you would do is you
would look at the landscape and you
would say okay there are these
superheroes who exist in New York that
show up and basically fight against
various threats and so on and so far
they found that guy named Thanos he's
giant and purple I'm not gonna fight him
because you could probably destroy me
yes he definitely could let us stop the
argument of Thanos versus apocalypse
Thanos would win so what would end up
happening here is he would say okay I'm
going to take the Avengers but he
wouldn't just do it based on power and
said what he would do is he would
analyze every facet of them so like what
their abilities were whether or not they
had any real measure of Hart different
things like that like it's a full
testing right so it's not just powers
because there's a lot of powerful people
out there who suck and so he would say
okay like we're gonna look at them in
their entirety and we're gonna like try
to find a way to basically ensure that I
could win so what he would do is he
would take Captain America most likely
like Captain America would become a
horseman of death he be or a horseman of
apocalypse he probably come like D
horsemen death is probably what he would
do we know that because apocalypse took
took like Warren Worthington who didn't
who literally couldn't do anything but
fly with angel wings it was kind of
weird but anyway um he would take
Captain America won because what Captain
America stands for the moral compass he
has then he would take a Hawkeye and or
maybe not Hawkeye I don't know why he
would want to take Hawkeye nobody wants
to take hard I'm sorry
jeremy renner you're awesome you were
great in 28 weeks later but until you
become Ronin I'm sorry man
you're the last one picked on the
kickball team so liddy would say so he
would probably take four just just to
show his power that he could take a god
he would take Captain America whatever
we'll just so he could take like Black
Widow and Hawkeye who cares you know but
he would have those folks at his
disposal did in turn what he would do is
he would say now we're going to launch a
campaign to test the world and to see
whether or not the world is capable of
defending itself and so if those
horsemen managed to destroy all the
other Avengers then he would in turn
implement his scheme to conquer the
world if the other Avengers were able to
overpower the horsemen then Epoque would
say okay they're worthy and he would
leave now there's one exception to that
rule and that's that apocalypse is
basically dying quote-unquote and when I
say dying I mean it's physical bodies
dying right like apocalypse does have a
spiritual essence and that spiritual
essence is kind of what ties on all the
abilities and everything that he has
what Marvel explained really during the
crossover where he kidnapped Nathan
summers is it apocalypse basically burns
out his body so he's like x-men made
great well he burns out his physical
bodies because his powers just so
extreme and so what he has to do is jump
from one host body to the next in order
to maintain his power now what ended up
happening here is a part one when that
was revealed it was Mama's kind of
statement that like apocalypse can
always come back and so what he'll do is
you'll basically try to put a spiritual
essence into a being who's sufficiently
powerful now there are people who can
sort of over powers of spiritual essence
of apocalypse x-man Nate gray is a
really good example but so can someone
like Franklin Richards different people
like that like they if they're if
they're cognizant of what's going on due
to their vast amount of power they can
just overpower and push out the
spiritual essence of apocalypse but if
this was an instance where apocalypse
had reawakened and he had shown up but
he had basically said my purpose of
doing this is because like I need a new
body he would not create horsemen what
he would do is he would show up and then
just like crush all the Avengers and
then say like I'm gonna take the body of
the most powerful one of you probably
the Incredible Hulk
I'm going to put my spirit in it I'm
going to take over the entirety of this
body now where the incredible Opie gets
a little fuzzy one we've never seen
apocalypse try that before but to you
it's not an easy thing to do because
fighting the Incredible Hulk in his mind
as we've seen when life was like devil
Hulk and all that kind of stuff
fighting the Incredible Hulk in his mind
is just as difficult as fighting
Incredible Hulk in the physical world so
it's not an easy thing to do but he
would take the body of somebody who
could basically continue to basically
withstand the vast amount of energy he
has which would likely be the Incredible
Hulk earth or and then in turn like go
forward doing whatever it is that he
wants to do so again it depends on what
it is now if that were the case if the
if the idea was he was just trying to
find a new host body while the Avengers
have to do was just hold him off because
usually apocalypse will do that with the
intention of transferring the body
immediately which basically means that
like he's running short on time so so
the idea here is that if apocalypse were
looking for a new body he would just
show up on his own he would face off
against the Avengers and he would decide
which one could hold all his energies
which would probably be the Incredible
Hulk he would wipe out the rest of the
Avengers he would subdue the Hulk take
him over and then transfer his
consciousness into Hulk's body which in
turn would wipe away the banner and
whole personas and leave only apocalypse
in his place in charge of the infinite
strength that the Incredible Hulk has
that's the only real caveat now because
that's the case and because apocalypse
despite all of his abilities is not like
all-powerful and cannot with you know
cannot withstand like every superhero on
earth for example then what would happen
here is apocalypse would basically be
overpowered by the Avengers where the
very least it'd be a stalemate
they would hold him off and then his
would basically lose his physical body
or he would retreat or he would he would
find some way to basically run off and
try to keep himself alive we don't
really know what steps he would take but
that's basically it I don't know it'd be
kind of interesting that's the only real
caveat the only real way to truly defeat
apocalypse because nobody in the MCU is
powerful enough to take him off on and
take him out on his own there huh like
when the Inhumans in the in the uncanny
x-men teamed up against apocalypse to
save Nate one of the things they
realized was apocalypse was fighting
with like desperation but he it wasn't
just fighting for the sake of fighting
he was fighting with like the wrath of
God and like overpowered them all like
it was it was nuts like his his power
was extreme I don't know I still say
that with the Incredible Hulk the
Avengers could hold him off without the
Incredible Hulk no way his Thor even
Thor's not powerful enough even if he
was his powers not infinite right like
like when Thor fought apocalypse during
uncanny Avengers he didn't have Muhl
near which is the one exception he just
had your arm joint and he had to get it
magically enchanted in order to in order
to defeat apocalypse but didn't actually
have Mjolnir with him if he had maybe he
could have won I don't know I don't let
me know what you guys think down in the
comment section but would that being
said if you are new here to comment
explained make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
you